I was adopted by a white missionary
couple I was adopted immediately placed
for adoption I was in foster care with
one family for 18 years they were white
my parents loved us and I understand
that but at the same time they took the
idea that they were saving me saving us
from ourselves being saved and I should
be grateful for the life that I've been
given because any child on the
reservation would give anything to live
as I was living they took us away from
our mom
they came marching right in and
literally took us and thousands of other
children from their home it's a way to
right eradicate us and to go to a
nation's children
is one of the sure ways to do that
[Music]
the US has a long and brutal legacy of
attempting to eradicate Native Americans
for centuries they colonized Native
American lands and murdered their
populations they forced them west and
pushed them into small confined patches
of land but Native Americans resisted a
Board of Indian Commissioners report
said instead of dying out under the
light and contact of civilization the
Indian population is steadily increasing
and that was an obstacle to total
American expansion so the u.s. found a
new solution to absorb and assimilate
them it all started with an experiment
and a man named Richard Henry Pratt he
had in his charge some prisoners of war
and he taught these men how to speak
English how to read and write and how to
do labor he dressed them in military
uniforms and basically ran an
assimilation experiment and then he took
his results to the federal government
and said they're capable of being
civilized so he was able to get this
project funded in 1879 the government
funded Pratt's project the first-ever
off-reservation boarding school for
Native American children his motto was
to kill the Indian and save the man
what started there at the Carlisle
Indian industrial school was nothing
short of genocide disguised as American
education children were forcibly taken
from reservations and placed into the
school hundreds even thousands of miles
away from their families they were
stripped of their traditional clothing
their hair was cut short they were given
new names and forbidden from speaking
their native languages to take our
children and to indoctrinate them into
Western society to take away their
identity as indigenous peoples their
tribal identity I think it's one of the
most effective and insidious ways that
the u.s. did do harm to indigenous
peoples here because it targeted our
children our most vulnerable and they
tried to make us ashamed for being
Indian and they tried to make us
something other than Indian there are
also accounts of mental physical and
sexual abuse of forced manual labor
neglect starvation and death my great
grandfather went to Carlisle and nobody
in my family ever talked about it so if
you google Indian boarding schools the
majority of the pictures that you will
see will be actually from Carlisle
Colonel Pratt created propaganda he
hired a photographer to create those
before-and-after photos to show that his
experiment was working so he it was you
know intentional propaganda and it
worked the Carlisle model of Education
swept the country and led to the
creation of over 350 boarding schools to
assimilate Native American children to
these boys and girls have ever seen a
white man yet through the agencies of
the government they are being rapidly
brought from their state of comparative
savagery and barbarism to one of
civilization in 1900 there were about
20,000 Native American children in these
schools by 1925 that number more than
tripled families that refused to send
their kids to these schools faced
consequences like incarceration at
Alcatraz or the withholding of food
rations some parents who did lose their
children to these schools even camped
outside to be close to them many
students ran away some found ways to
hold on to their languages and cultures
others though could no longer
communicate with family members and some
never returned home at all by stripping
the children of their Native American
identities the US government had found a
way to disconnect them from their lands
and that was part of the u.s. strategy
during the same era in which thousands
of children were sent away to boarding
schools a number of US policies
infringed on their tribal lands back
home in less than five decades
two-thirds of Native American lands had
been taken away the whole thing was
purposeful and the fact that it has been
buried in the history books and not
acknowledged is also intentional and in
fact the same tactics were used in New
Zealand Australia Canada all of these
countries have acknowledged apologized
or reconciled in some way except for the
United States over time the brutality of
boarding schools started to surface and
after a 1928 report detailed the
horrific conditions at some schools many
began to close in the 1960s indigenous
activism rose alongside the civil rights
movement and by the 1970s that activism
forced more schools to shut down the
government handed over control of the
remaining boarding schools to tribes to
be run in partnership with the Bureau of
Indian Affairs but just as the boarding
school era started fading another
assimilation project took shape adoption
[Music]
the main goal of this pilot project was
to stimulate the adoption of American
Indian children to primarily non-indian
adoptive homes they claimed it was to
promote the adoption of the Forgotten
child but it was essentially a
continuation of the boarding school
assimilation tactics and the strategy
came with a financial advantage for the
government to adoption was cheaper than
running boarding schools but first
adoption officials had to sell white
America on the idea of adopting Native
American children feature stories like
this one in Good Housekeeping marketed
them to white families they were
described as unwanted and adoption gave
them a chance at new lives in the end
their media campaign worked white
families wanted Indian adoption but the
problem was many of these children were
not orphans that nobody wanted they were
kids often ripped apart from families
that wanted to keep them you still will
hear stories today of people you know my
age older saying I remember as a child
the social worker was coming and people
would hide their children on
reservations social workers used
catch-all phrases like child neglect or
unfit parenting as evidence for removal
but their criteria was often
questionable some accounts describe
children being taken away for living
with too many family members in the same
household an extended family is a big
thing for Native people and that means
being judged for being in a house that's
overcrowded so it's always whiteness is
the standard for success and everything
else is judged by that standard
by the 1960s about one in four Native
children were living apart from their
families
the official Indian adoption project
placed 395 Native American children into
mostly white homes but it was just one
of many in an era of Native American
adoptions other state agencies and
private religious organizations began
increasingly making placements for
Native American children - my mother
giving me up was a white person telling
her if she didn't she would never see
her other kids again and one of the
documents I have it's addressed to my
biological father Victor Fox that he was
trying to look us up to get a hold of us
but Hennepin County wrote Daniel and
Douglas are adapting very well and their
new family just was totally it was a
false statement when you're adopted you
know you're missing something I think
I've likened it to having like when
someone has like a 500 piece puzzle and
they have all the pieces to make this
pretty picture except one my adoptive
mother was not well verbally physically
and sexually and spiritually abusive so
by the by the time I was 14 I started
drinking 15 drugs are added and I became
an addict to numb I didn't realize I was
numbing pain I had tried suicide tried
to slice in my wrists one time children
were taken
and believe like I believed for a long
time there was something wrong with me
versus something wrong with the system
the Indian adoption project was
considered a success by the people who
set it in motion officials claimed
generally speaking we believe the Indian
people have accepted the adoption of
their children by Caucasian families and
have been pleased to learn the
protection afforded these children but
the truth was unsettling these hearings
on Indian children's welfare is now in
session
I was pregnant with Bobby and the
welfare kept coming over there and asked
me if I gave him up for adoption
before he was even born yeah they picked
up my children and placed him in a
foster home and I think that they were
abused in a foster home for years after
Native people organized in this Senate
hearing Congress passed the Indian Child
Welfare Act known as equi it gives
tribes a place at the table in court
states would be required to provide
services to families to prevent removal
of an Indian child and in case removal
was necessary they would have to try to
keep the child with extended family or
another Native American family without
our relatives we cease to exist
so with Native people part of our wealth
is in our family it's in who we're
connected to but the legacy of family
separation in Native communities has
been difficult to fully undo today
Native American children are four times
more likely to be placed in foster care
than white children even when their
families have similar presenting
problems in these cases equi is often
the best legal protection they have and
it's been under attack repeatedly a
young girl ripped from her foster family
because of the Indian children welfare
act white adoptive families intent on
keeping Native American children have
tried to do away with the act and
they're often backed by conservative
organizations the Indian Child Welfare
Act was dealt a blow earlier this month
the subject of a lawsuit issued on
Tuesday by the Goldwater Institute
arguing that preferences given to
American Indian families to adopt Indian
children is unconstitutional and
discriminates based on race it's a way
for these industries these very powerful
industries to try to attack what Indian
identity is wanting to overturn nikla is
connected to everything about who we are
as a nation so if we don't have any
protections for our families and if we
don't have protections for our treaties
then we have no more Indians we've been
under attack we're going to continue to
be under attack and we have to keep just
keep fighting it's in our DNA to survive
we are nations that pre-exists European
contact and we are still here
[Music]
you
[Music]